federal agents are dumping thousands of
illegal aliens at bus stations and then
simply walking away they don't want to
do it they have no choice Congress won't
help them our system is in total
collapse nobody's even trying to protect
you or our country Kirsten Gillibrand is
the US Senator and a Democratic
presidential candidate she thinks what
is happening is just fine on Sunday
Gillibrand went on television to explain
that we have no right to detain illegal
immigrants instead they should be
released directly into our country but
you oppose even what the Obama
administration did in terms of keeping
families together or keeping them
together for a longer period of time in
detention
I wouldn't as president United States I
wouldn't use the detention system at all
Homeland Security those saying hundreds
of thousands of people are crossing the
border and they need to go somewhere
before their Asylum claims are actually
heard what would you do with them they
don't need to be incarcerated they can
if they're given a lawyer and given a
process they will follow it it goes that
saying that functioning societies don't
operate like this countries that care
about their people enforce their own
laws our leaders are decadent and
narcissistic they care only about
themselves they will never defend our
nation that's obvious and the rest of
the world knows that the American pinata
has been getting pummeled for decades
and now it has finally come apart our
national wealth is up for grabs by
whomever get gets here first and they
are coming over just the past year 1% of
the entire population of the nation of
Guatemala has moved to the United States
wall street journal' piece last month
described the plight of that country's
villages some of them are literally
depopulating as people stream north to
America's generous welfare state
meanwhile a new study from the
Federation for American immigration
reform fare given exclusively to this
show shows the scale on which the United
States is being plundered every year
fair found foreign-born workers send
about a hundred and fifty billion
dollars in remittances to their friends
and family overseas that's more than the
GDP of 18 American states illegal aliens
alone are emitting twenty eight billion
dollars a year
that's twenty eight billion dollars
leaving this country going abroad every
year from people who don't even have the
legal right to work here in the first
place but are and are benefiting of
course from all the extras free health
care free education subsidized housing
food stamps who knows what else the
remittances are not taxed in the case of
illegal immigrants working under the
table
their original earnings have never been
taxed either so this is a disaster but
it's not a natural disaster we could
have prevented it with a wall mandatory
e-verify remittance taxes and efficient
deportation process you could easily fix
this crisis it wouldn't take much it's
not fixed because Congress doesn't want
to fix it